لم ينتهي الشهر الاول من عام 2023 بعد لكن
يبدو انه سيكون عام الاختبارات على الاقل
بالنسبه لاتفاق النووي المترنحه هل سيبقى
ام سيدفن فكل المحادثات التي اجريت في
اغسطس الماضي لاحياء تعثرت بعد توتر
العلاقات بين ايران والاطراف الغربيه
المعنيه بما فيها الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل متزايد كل ذلك
بسبب الحمل الصارمه الدمويه التي يشونها
النظام الايراني ضد المتظاهرين عدا عن
بيعها لطائرات مسيرات عسكريه لروسيا في
هذا السياق حتى بريطانيا اعادت النظر في
دعمها للاتفاق النووي الايرانيه عام 2015
بعد اعدام المواطن البريطاني الايراني علي
رضا اكبر وفق ما ذكرت صحيفه
كما واعلنت بريطانيا التي تعد طرفا رئيسا
في المحادثات النوويه التي تستهدف احياء
الاتفاق استدعاء السفيرها من ايران مؤقتا
للتشاور ردا على اعدام اكبر وقال مصدر
حكومي انه خلال فتره المفاوضات تغير
المشهد وتغيرت المعطيات بشكل كامل بسبب
سلوك النظام الايراني فيما اشار 10 داونكس
الى ان جميع الخيارات قيد المراجعه اي ان
بريطانيا التي كانت متفائله بحذر بشان
اعاده احياء ان يتفاق النووي يبدو انها
تراجع موقفها مليا طبعا دون ان ننسى ان
الاتفاق بالنسبه للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
شبه ميت بالفعل منذ ديسمبر الماضي حتى
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه رايات جراسي اكد ان المفاوضات
النوويه مع ايران وصلت الى طريق مسدوده
وتوقفت اما وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
كلافلي فاضح ان رد بلاده على اي بخصوص
اعدام اكبري لن يقتصر على ما تم اتخاذه من
اجراءات مشيرا الى ان المزيد قيد الدراسه
واضحه الى النظام الايراني مفادها اننا
نراقب عن كثب ما يفعلونها وسنرد بقوه على
اي اجراءات يتخذونها وعليهم ان يدركوا ان
الاحتجاجات التي يشهدونها في جميع انحاء
ايران هي مظاهرات شعبيه مدفوعه بسبب
الاجراءات التي يتخذونها ضد الشعوب بهم